just to pick up where we left off right
you've got l1 here and l2 over here what
we're after are the pair of lines and
there are two that will bisect the
angles in a right they have to bisect
the angles and you're going to get two
because whatever line bisects this angle
over here will bisect that one and vice
versa so two lines are what we're
looking for okay now we also have done
Part A which said based on the
perpendicular distance formula which
said for some point P and that's where
we have drawn one okay if it's
coordinates are variable so we'll just
call them X comma Y right whatever those
values may be then what we determined
was this we use the perpendicular
distance formula on both of these guys
and by Part A we had established this
geminus yeah so you remember we ended
out a little bit because we thought hold
on but these are not these are not equal
to each other in what in what world are
they equal to each other and the answer
is in the world where they follow the
rules of this particular point because
this point doesn't just go anywhere
randomly it follows very specific
geometric rules it can only be in
certain places X&Y can only be related
instead west okay and then Part B said
hence hence use this thing to work out
these equations right no ten theater
equals m1 minus m2 on one plus you know
none of that business I'm so late well
yeah no no just going from scratch
finding where a is and then just trying
to do some point gradient business in
there we just had to go from a we just
had to go from it so here's my
suggestion for our step forward okay
what point what this is mine represents
right is the relationships between x and
y such that i'll be somewhere on these
angle bisector lines okay but there's
too much that's unknown here there's too
much there are four unknowns foreigners
and I've hope you've got one equation
okay so I've got to try and Sal got two
unknowns I've got an x and a y but I've
got them on both sides okay I need to
narrow it down a little bit
so therefore I'm gonna start by saying
this when X 0 now this is a big deal
right this is one of those crucial steps
where before this year like what
direction do I go in and then once you
start this ball rolling you know okay
now I know what to do but here is why
this makes sense I'm gonna say when x
equals zero because on this diagram
right I can actually and this is why
it's important you have a diagram I can
draw what these angle bisectors are
doing even if it's not perfect I can do
it pretty close right so for example
where I've drawn P at the moment the
whole series of points on that line look
kind of like this do you agree at that
you see that anywhere along that black
line I'm going to bisecting this angle
here it's maybe 45 45 because these two
lines are at right angles to each other
okay
so there's a whole bunch now I don't
used to keep going right in the same way
right there's that other angle bisector
and it's gonna do something like this
okay now there's my pair of angle
bisectors and I'm after these two
equations okay what do you notice about
these two is that just like every other
straight line out there that isn't just
horizontal or vertical I can do this and
what will I get when I solve this
I'll get intercepts why not I'll get Y
into sense right what is this what
values am I expecting something like
that which is between a half and three
right and something like this who knows
where that is okay but that's what I
should find when I go ahead and solve
this right so when x equals zero I just
put that in here I'm gonna get this
how do that just all the excerpts have
disappeared now this you like hold on a
second kid is an absolute value equal to
an absolute value was seeing these
before there are going to be two
solutions to this which is exactly what
we are anticipating right so let's have
a look at this how would you how would
you work out like you could do this by
cases what would be the quickest way
yeah yes that's exactly right
but this really means plus or minus this
and this really means plus or minus this
as well okay
min-soo do you wanna suggest something
that's exactly right I could do that
obsessed equals here's kind of the
approach I'm going to take just imagine
for a second this is y minus 3 and minus
2 y plus 1 right when we usually see one
variable we're used to solving in terms
of X okay so if I just put over on the
side here right if what my asked you saw
was this okay I could visualize this
this is the HUD should visualize X minus
3 what does X minus 3 is a line usually
look like it's the normal line that goes
through the origin but it's been shifted
down three units or to the right three
units in a linear function those are the
same thing does that make sense good
look hey I think I'm moving down or
moving to the right they're both the
same
okay now I've got an absolute value on
it so that means it looks like this yeah
be that okay so there's the left-hand
side what is the right hand side look
like roughly speaking I'm gonna have my
intercept at 1 right which is which is
lower down because that's 3 isn't it and
because that minus 2 it's going to be
steep and going down so it's gonna do
this and then it's gonna balance back up
with you're happy with that ok now this
is super super rough but it's it's clear
enough to see like I don't need to worry
about this branch over here do I
completely irrelevant
I'm never gonna intersect with that
branch I'm just gonna forget about it ok
what's the equation of this spreadsheet
the very first one that I drew
think about it yeah okay it's gonna be
minus X cuz it's decreasing and plus 3
or 3 minus X if you're like putting on -
I know this just turns it around right
just think back to you actually berry so
therefore you clear that is 3 minus X
okay and then of course to get these two
I'm just going to solve it for both
cases right minus 2x plus 1 and 2x minus
1 okay does that make sense of what
we're doing now that's all in terms of
X's what we actually have is wise it's
all exactly the same it's just a
different label ok so now here in the
two cases I'm going to solve I can
ignore Y minus 3 as a case because I
just showed I'm never going to actually
intersect with that
so here's case 1 3 minus y equals this
and here's case 2 3 minus y equals that
ok this is not too hard we could do this
together what's this one gonna be equal
to you could do it in one line right
yeah - why both sides so you're gonna
get Y and you subtract 3 from both sides
and you get minus 2 minus 2 where's that
that's clearly this guy isn't it right
now obviously my scales not great but
it's obvious to note like one's positive
ones negative right so clearly that's
not what I'm talking about
you haven't got yes what am I going to
do
you agree that yeah if you want to go
the other way around
I'll add Y to both sides which makes
this three white and then I add one to
both sides strings it's four and I just
flip it around the way that makes Y the
subject
so Y is 4/3 what bow is that mean yeah
so now I've got two Y values y
intercepts I should say to get the
equation of the line I can take a whole
variety different parts see if I knew
what a was right I gave you 2 point
formula that would work okay but surely
I can do this in a faster way right
especially taking advantage of what I've
just done
yeah yeah right if I can find out these
two one two then I can put this into two
intercept form which we saw is a really
really simple way to get the equation of
a line so I'm gonna go when y equals
here when y equals 0 my Y terms are
gonna disappear up here so I'm gonna go
to X minus X plus 1 absolute value again
for some rough working to save myself
time in terms of working out the cases
I'm just gonna do a super rough squish
sketch of this guy right let's have a
look
X plus 1 how'd you describe it it's
shifted to the left or chipped it up
with which I'll put the same thing okay
it's gone that way now 2 X minus 3 would
normally be down here wouldn't it okay
so it's actually going to be here we
kind of have a mirror image of what we
have at the top which is partly a
coincidence based on these coefficients
that we have here
okay all of that just to say which which
case which partners can I ignore safely
this part over here irrelevant right
so therefore what's the equation of this
part it's it's this partly the first one
I drew is at the plus one and then the
other two is just what I'm going to take
both cases right so that's my heart so X
plus one equals one case and X plus one
equals the other case
oops
yes yeah okay now you go ahead you check
your values Matt you look does it kinda
make sense does that look like
two-thirds and does that look like for
sure enough okay great
I'm almost there what do I want I want
the equations of these two things okay
so one of the reasons why the diagram is
so powerful is unlike this which is like
which X in which Y match up answer
okay it's not obvious at all here though
right two thirds and minus 2 like you
know the line is going right through
there okay so let's do the first
equation I'm going to call it angle
bisector one because that's what it's
doing angle bisector one obviously you
can call whichever one okay what's two
intercepts for them to intercept form is
X on the X intercepts which I'm going to
pick that two-thirds one yep plus y on
the y intercept which its corresponding
one is minus two and that's equal to one
so I want this in general form so what
shall I do to this to make it general
form what should I multiply through by
now want you to remember right this is
one of the I admit this is all no point
no form is perfect right so the problem
here is you got fractions on fractions
this is not really a 3 on the bottom
though is it it's actually a 3 on the
top because you're dividing by the 2/3
so really I've got a denominator of 2
here and a denominator of 2 here does
that make sense so I'm just gonna
multiply by 2
that'll do it I'm gonna put in the next
parameter set so that's X on 4 plus y on
4/3 and that's equal to 1 so Y
multiplied by 4x plus 3y minus 4
to angle bisectors